- To what do I owe the pleasure,
you old sandbagging son of a bitch?
How are you doing?
Oh my god.
50 stitches, he's gonna look like
a Bond villain.
- Hey!
Shut up!
- Hey guys.
- Hey.
New haircut?
- Yeah.
- Looks nice.
- Thank you.
- It'll grow out.
(laughing)
- Oh my god.
This is so funny, oh my god.
(laughing)
- I don't care what you're laughing at.
Stop trying to get me to ask you.
- It's so funny.
- No.
- Sorry guys, I'm in a rush right now.
- What, what, hey.
Get to the back of the line, man.
- Alright, look buddy.
I got a meeting in three minutes, alright.
- We all have the same meeting.
Get to the back.
- Sorry, traffic.
- We were getting coffee.
- Things were going really well,
but she hasn't text me
for like three days.
- Well maybe she's been busy?
- She's not into you, man.
You gotta move on.
- Do you think you two will have
the project done by tomorrow?
- Absolutely not.
- Yeah.
- No.
- Definitely.
- Hey Devon, did you
get my Facebook invite?
- Yeah.
- You coming?
- No, not a chance.
- We're going to Loud Bar,
kind of like a pick me up for Garrett.
- That bar's awful and so expensive,
such a long line.
Let's go to Wavy Dance, better atmosphere.
I'll buy a round, you know.
Garrett's at least.
- What's your drink?
- [Garrett] Frozen margarita.
- Yeah, I'mma get you an old fashioned.
- [Garrett] Okay.